we know taylor swift can spit drake's
bars while running
and now fans are sweating over the duo
possibly teaming up for a collab
check this out drake just shared this
snapshot hugging taylor from behind with
his arm around her neck loving it and
the caption they too soft to understand
the meaning of hard work which sparked
fans to speculate the two are working
together i like challenges swifties know
she loves teasing new music and dropping
easter eggs so let's get into some
theories about this potential
collaboration number one the order of
the photos the pick drake posted with
the 32 year old singer is the fifth
slide and with t-swift gearing up for
the re-release of her fifth album 1989
fans think it's hardly a coincidence
baby
and i'll write your name
theory number two taylor's unconfirmed
and never released album karma the
speculation here is that taylor had an
album called karma but canceled it back
in 2016 after her feud with kim
kardashian and kanye west reignited i am
still trying to understand the whole
feud between taylor swift and yay that
happened about this whole song because i
thought she knew about it
she did but she was acting like she
didn't
up until that point she had released a
new album and new look every two years
between 2006 and 2014 but just three
months before this alleged album was
supposedly to be released taylor
received backlash after kanye released
his single famous
by myself sat does that know me best i
feel like me and taylor might still have
sex why i made that famous
so fans think she shelved karma to
instead drop reputation an album that
directly addressed the kimye chaos in
2017.
rumors about taylor and drake
collaborating were first reported
between 1989 and reputation which just
so happens to be when karma would have
been released meaning the collab
theories with drake fits the timeline
for a feature on the rumored karma album
but turns out there may not be any story
here
yeah e.t has learned that the pick is in
fact old and there is no collab in the
works the pair has been friends for a
while taylor even name-dropped drake on
her song i forgot that you existed and i
couldn't get away from ya
and my feelings more than drake's oh
yeah and all the way back in 2011 the 35
year old rapper tweeted to the singer
i'm so proud of you so for now we're
gonna shake off the rumors
but cross our fingers for a collab in
our wildest dreams
[Music]
especially if it's in god's plan god's
plan
god's plan